after years of being off and on
cardi b and offset are off again
e.t ken confirmed that the wap rapper
filed for divorce from 28 year old
offset on tuesday in fulton county
georgia
a hearing has been set for november 4th
and e.t has reached out to their reps
for comment
cardi's divorce filing comes after she
recently commented on how
solid their relationship was telling
elle magazine
in their september issue that while she
knows her relationship has
a lot of drama there's also a lot of
love
passion trust and a big friendship
cardi also alluded to her husband's
alleged infidelity
quote there's always rumors about me and
my husband
and i feel like people would rather
start rumors because they want me to be
heartbroken
they want me to be hurt the rapper last
posted about offset on
august 20th when she promoted his group
migos's
new music video
and here's offset's last post about his
now estranged wife
from august 7th in addition to sharing
this
kiss pic the rapper also praised cardi's
wap
music video writing in part quote so
proud of my wife
she works so hard and her creativity and
mind is out of this world
[Music]
seven days a week cardian offset tied
the knot in september
2017 but they kept their marriage a
secret until the following june
at the time the bronx native tweeted our
relationship was
so new breaking up and making up and we
had a lot of growing up to do
but we was so in love we didn't want to
lose each other
was one morning in september we woke up
and
decided to get married cardi continued
quote
we found someone to marry us and she did
just the two of us
and my cousin i said i do with no dress
no makeup and no ring
the couple's daughter culture was born
in july 2018
one month after cardi publicly revealed
that they had tied the knot
i just want to show people how beautiful
and how precious she is she's so
precious
seriously